st george is in liverpool more than 200
years old and full of reasons to let in
the cold
the house of god is no exception to the
worry being felt in homes across britain
soaring energy prices are prompting the
vicar to rethink when to put the lights
on when to use the sound system
it's meant to be a financial crisis
affecting the cost of living but he's
even considering restricting the days on
which to hold funerals to coincide with
other events when the heating is already
on
did you ever imagine that you'd be in
this situation uh no no no i never
imagined that it hadn't crossed my mind
until my treasurer told me our heating
bill has is is going over it's doubling
and i might go off again
the last thing they want to do is pass
increased costs onto their community
which is one of the most deprived
parishes in england
the church has a food pantry but the
vicar's wife who connects food
organizations in liverpool says they
can't even think about expanding their
services when they're in fear of what
the energy companies will announce next
we'd love to be something that's called
a heat bank or a warm space just for
people to visit this winter but
that's something we're just not able to
offer here the cost of energy and
heating it's just too high for us
across liverpool at another food pantry
like many other places they're coping
with a drop in donations
a few months ago we were reporting on
the shock of food banks short of food by
late summer that appears to be
widespread the worrying trend now is
being driven by unaffordable energy
prices
people pick things up like biscuits
because it's something to eat
rather than something that they have to
cut they just haven't got the fuel they
haven't got the means to cook it it's
disgraceful it's like living in in
dickensian britain it's like victorian
times we shouldn't be living like this
and people will die
it's alma's first time in the food
pantry she's battling a range of
emotions
the need to come to a food bank is
actually and i don't want to sound
condescending but it is demeaning for a
lot of people
hello we went to see alma at home so
this is the house you're struggling to
keep warm turns out at the age of 80
almost not just angry but also defiant
she is one of the first voices we've
heard openly revolting against paying
energy bills
i wouldn't pay them
even if i could afford to because i
think it's
wicked and wrong what's going on how far
are you prepared to take this enough is
enough we're not going to pay they can't
possibly jail all of us
the energy companies and the government
are deciding what happens next no one
can say they haven't been warned about
the mood of those bearing the costs lisa
holland sky news liverpool